on va voir à présent la situation en
afrique alors que le continent avait été
beaucoup moins touché par la pandémie
que l'amérique l'om est hier à présent
la sonnette d'alarmé
le nombre de cas sur le continent
connaît une progression constante sur
les six semaines consécutives avec
notamment une hausse de 25% au cours du
mois de juin et le sénégal elle
n'échappe pas à cette hausse des
contaminations
voyez les précisions de notre
correspondante à dakar l île à faa'a
musou même si la cour des décès restent
encore maîtrisable force est de
constater que le corona virus gagne du
terrain
ici au sénégal avec notamment une
propagation galopante de quatre
variantes dont le variant delta qui
préoccupent tout particulièrement ici
plus contagieux plus agressif il a déjà
été signalé dans 16 pays africains et le
sénégal n'y échappe pas alors plusieurs
causes à cette hausse des contaminations
la fin de l'état d'urgence les
rassemblements populaires ou encore la
reprise des activités et puis un élément
à prendre en compte ici nous sommes
entrés dans la saison des pluies où les
températures peuvent atteindre les 45
degrés ce qui rend le port du masque
très minoritaires comme on a pu le
constater dans les rues dakaroise la
masse qu'il faut l'aider c'est un peu
gênant parce que ça étouffe et tout ça
avec la charia comme pour les pick up
aussi la masse
ça 505 et du coup on est obligé d'en
lieu d'enlever on a constaté que y'en a
pas assez de deux ans qu'ils respectent
management mais je me suis dit non
seulement les respecter les mauges
barrière ça ne suffit pas tout
simplement le masque il faut d'abord il
faudrait d'abord en tout cas de
désengagement personnel et parce que
chacun d'entre nous ne vous ne veut pas
être athée en tout cas sa maladie l'a
donc il ya pire nous ne devons pas lui
tout simplement à la part des masques
pour les habitants la population
sénégalaise non respectueux les mesures
de beria à savoir les masques les
distances ils ne respectent plus que ça
c'est pour ça qu'il ya toujours la
hausse du bus des enfants fatigués ne
masque pas ses lignes ils disent que ça
étouffe les masques nous protège face à
cette flambée des nouveaux cas le comité
national de gestion des épidémies a
convoqué une réunion en urgence pour
évaluer la stratégie mise en place
jusqu'à présent et préparer la riposte
notamment à travers la vaccination reste
à convaincre une population qui se
montrent majoritairement méfiante
vis-à-vis des vaccins
rappelons ce chiffre de l'om est ce à ce
jour 15 millions de personnes sont
vaccinées sur le continent ce qui
représente à peine 1,2 pour cent de la
population africaine